thank you in 2010 when i arrived at
DARPA we were faced with a following
problem which is that the military sends
millions of its members across the globe
and in many of those places there is no
medical infrastructure so if somebody
falls ill there's no minute clinic or
physician's office or even a
phlebotomist to take a blood sample and
so we were faced with the challenge of
how do we diagnose this individual in a
robust accurate way no matter where in
the world they may be located and so we
invested in two technologies one enable
that individuals to collect their own
blood sample and number to enable that
sample to be shipped back to a clinical
lab without having to be packed on ice
and as those technologies began to pay
off we began to realize that it could
have a huge impact way beyond the
military but on personalized medicine
today the conversation has been
completely constrained around genetic
sequencing well sequence your genome
we'll look at your variations and we'll
figure out what your risk profile is but
what you really want to know or what I
want to know is am I developing that
disease and my development it tomorrow
am I currently developing it and the
challenge is that genetics tells us fate
it doesn't tell us state and that's
actually the information that we want to
measure in to capture now the genome is
largely static and what you want is the
dynamic information that's carried by
the RNA and the proteins that are being
not only expressed off the genome but
are being impacted by your environment
and that are actually a reflection of
your real-time state of health and this
information is dynamic it's not static
now you may say to me Alicia well we
already collect this dynamic information
we do but we don't throughout the course
of our lives from birth to death we only
measure these biomarkers a handful of
times we measure them at some age
specific checkups and then we measure
them when we're ill and we don't compare
them to ourselves in our healthy state
but we only compare them to when we are
a population average which is not
reflective of ourselves what would be
much more powerful as if we could track
these levels dynamically
frequently over time in periods of
wellness and in periods of illness and
through this information begin to be
able to develop the ability to actually
predict not only disease onset but our
treatment course and the impact of those
treatments let me make this very
specific there is a cancer biomarker
known as cancer antigen 125 and it's
novarian cancer biomarker and it uses a
threshold test so if your level of ca125
is above the threshold you're considered
to have cancer but most clinicians will
tell you it's way too late the other
challenge is that even if you test below
the threshold most early cancer patients
measure already below the threshold the
result being that most people who are
then diagnosed with ovarian cancer are
already in the latest stages when it's
least curable what's going on here
what's going on is that we're using a
population average and assuming that
that average threshold is the same for
every single one of us the other
challenge is that all of all the women
in this room our levels of ca125 vary
anywhere from 70 to forty seven to forty
percent over the course of a month and
so what would be much more effective as
if we could track those levels over time
and understand what is normal for us and
indeed there was a group in the UK who
just published a study last year that
looked at 50,000 women over the course
of a decade in which they measured their
levels of ca125 is infrequently as every
year and as frequently as every 12 weeks
and the result was a sounding what they
found was that regardless of the initial
and final magnitude of the ca125
measurement if they saw the measurement
double over the period of six months
they were able to diagnose eighty-six
percent cases of ovarian cancer doubling
the effectiveness of the biomarker and
this isn't just the case for ca-125 and
ovarian cancer but it's the case for
many biomarkers that are currently
correlated with things like
neurodegenerative disease other
types of cancer and oncology and
cardiovascular disease and so what we
can sense that we're very close to a
near future we're just by changing the
way that we measure biomarkers that are
already fda-approved we don't have to
discover anymore we can dramatically
increase their effectiveness but it's
predicated on being able to take this
frequent blood sample and as any of you
know who've given a blood sample
recently are gone to a blood draw center
the user experience is atrocious what we
need is a way that is a seamless to our
course of care as when your doctor uses
a stethoscope or a tongue depressor on
you you want something that can be
implemented quickly and seamlessly even
so that you can do it in your own home
and the key insight that we had at DARPA
and that I am currently building right
now is that those same technologies that
enabled us to acquire and transport a
sample from a soldier anywhere in the
world are the same technologies that can
enable us to acquire a sample anywhere
in our healthcare system and anywhere in
our daily lives thank you
you